le pape admet elle est toujours la cote
[Musique]
je sais que isabelle morini bosc avait
craqué pour vous ouais j'avais une non
je trouve vraiment un des plus beaux
visages que j'ai vue dans ma vie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours un peu loin
impossible alors je suis seulement
surtout quand vous chantez magnifique il
avait eu beaucoup d'appels c'est
vraiment votre style si vous n'étiez pas
ma sur marié voilà vous auriez pu avoir
une aventure avec valartis travers vous
inquiétez pas ils vont pas voir la
voiture en direct vous inquiétez pas
tant de la cie sa femme avait pas été
aussi jolie et s'il avait été limé les
célibataires lui bien sûr ça va ça si
les raisons et surtout non mais il est
célibataire
bah oui navin pourriez lui demander
comment il a trouvé aussi c'est sûr
qu'ils accourent belle isabelle et ses
contours et bell helicopter in 2000
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
isabelle vous le dit on au parquet sur
les méchants
isabelle vous êtes splendide franchement
rien couple magnifique mais oui il va
écouter excusé le 1
voilà moi en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est pas des pieds isabelle les mariés
mais il est libre après voiture arrive
tu te rends compte qu'on est à la
télévision une des émissions dur d'y
regarder de france en direct et on y va
me parler des plans de mon père quoi
à moi un autre rappeur qui va parler
d'eux c'est vrai mais pas par email à
son goût